ich bin die orascom aus der
südsteiermark bezirk leibnitz mein ziel
ist es dann auf die militärakademie zu
gehen
in irgendeiner funktion beim bundesheer
dann tätig sein
erst einmal im internet geschaut dann
wie bei freunden um die schon vom
bundesheer waren unternehmen zum harris
personalien gegangen und hab glück name
informationen gewehrt ich hab mir aufs
schlimmste eingestellt gehabt das muss
so weit gehen dass die dann einfach
körperlich nahm accounts oder dass zum
beispiel die burschen seine körperlich
besser benannte sie doch nicht mitkommen
oder sonst irgendwo sagen das ist nicht
so schlimm der unterschied
für fußball im op-bereich macht viel
sport bin eigentlich ausnahme sexuelle
die gut an da kommt man dann er war
personen her den nix machen oder
körperlich nicht so kurz dass es dann so
anstrengend wie ist man wahrscheinlich
volk steht ja wenn's so privatmaschine
ist dass den kleinen rucksack duster
essen trinken eine vielleicht ein
regenschutz vom bundeshaus einmal den
großen rucksack kompaktvans länger
draußen bleibt nimmt die schlafsack
damit hast du das ganze paket an schönen
scheins gewicht dass der kampf westen
abwehr astana wurst herum zahlen muss
dann spaziert mit dem bergauf sondern
marschiert gießen am zügigen dem
portikus das ist nicht locker spazieren
gehe jetzt zum bergwandern schauen die
aussicht genießen sondern der gestern am
tempo
frau wäre eigentlich gleich behandelt
bin froh darüber wie nicht bevorzugt
werden und benachteiligt natürlich
handelt ich bin genauso soldaten wie
optisch der eindruck täuscht einjährig
freiwilliger und er muss genau das
gleiche morgan williams kehrt sie als am
anfang bei meinem team dass bin laden
aber eine mit einer frau reden würde zu
kanzler und einer frau zugs büro zu der
kanne gehen oder wenn überhaupt über die
militärakademie also mit jemandem reden
welche die frau hauptmann aus linswege
der anruf kommt vorbei und dreht mit mir
gibt tipps was einige anlaufstellen wo
ihr wenn ihr als frau zu einer frau
reden will reden kann